welcome to the man of recaps this is the
lord of the rings original trilogy it
begins with the fellowship of the ring
at the shire a beautiful place and home
of the hobbits there are peaceful folk
who love food and not going on
adventures except bilbo baggins who went
on a grand adventure in the hobbit with
his wizard friend gandalf the gray it's
bilbo's birthday and during his speech
he pulls a prank and disappears yes
during his adventure he found a magic
ring that turns him invisible but
there's something weird with the ring
it's very hard to give up but he manages
to do it and goes off to retire and so
the ring passes to his nephew frodo but
now get off suspicious so he throws the
ring in the fire which reveals the
secret engraving and it's very bad news
one ring to rule them all and in the
darkness bind them yeah way back in the
day they made a bunch of rings of power
we'll learn more about those
theoretically in the upcoming amazon
series but the dark lord sauron forged
in secret a master ring to rule them all
and like almost conquered the world with
it but the human king got a lucky shot
and cut the ring off his finger and
because he poured his life force into it
that killed him but sauron can't truly
die until the ring is destroyed and he
had this chance to do it but the ring
corrupts anyone who has it so he decided
to keep it for himself but after that
the ring was lost for a thousand years
until by chance the creature gollum
picked it up more on him later and there
in gollum's cave is where during the
hobbit bilbo baggins picked it up not
knowing how important it was so now
sauron's woken up and is hunting for the
ring they gotta get it out of here but
gandalf can't take it he's too strong it
would corrupt him immediately it has to
be frodo baggins a nice incorruptible
hobbit to carry it and he gets a partner
because his best friend slash gardener
samwise gamji was eavesdropping and
heard the whole thing so as gandalf
rides off to do important wizard
business frodo and sam set off on an
adventure turns out adventures are
mostly just walking like a comically
large amount of walking pretty soon
they're joined by two more hobbits the
goofsters mary and pippen but this
adventure's not all fun and games
they're being hunted by the mysterious
black riders they get to the prancing
pony where they're supposed to beat
gandalf but gandalf isn't here but there
is someone here watching them looking
super cool sitting in the corner the
mysterious ranger strider that night
freddo accidentally puts the ring on
which makes him invisible except to
sauron and now the black riders know
where he is strider grabs him but turns
out he's a good guy and he explains the
black riders are the nazgul the nine men
who had their own rings of power but are
now bound to sauron's will as ring rates
that night when they come to kill the
hobbit strider fools them with the old
pillow trick and now he's going to lead
our group on the next phase of walking
but hobbits aren't used to this much
walking they already stopped for one
breakfast yes but what about second
breakfast soon the nask will find him
and give frodo a nasty stab but strider
busts in there goes into beast mode and
scares him off frodo's in bad shape now
but someone comes to rescue him it's the
elf arwyn who is incidentally strider's
girlfriend she rides frodo out of there
and crosses the river just ahead of the
nazgul if you want him come and claim
him but boom she unleashes the river
power and washes the nas ghoul away
they're out of commission for a bit so
frodo's healed he wakes up in a nice
comfy bed where gandalf's here nice of
you to join us he went to see his wizard
boss sorum on the white but turns out
saruman's turned evil we must join with
sauron they have a wizard's battle but
soroman wins and traps again off on the
top of his tower but eventually gandalf
found a moth cellphone and called an
uber from the eagles and flew on out of
there so they made it to rivendell home
of the elves but lord elrond has bad
news sauron's too strong the ring cannot
stay here so they hold a big council to
decide what to do with it the human
boromir of gondor is like yo this is
awesome let's use it to against sauron
but you can't do that the ring super
evil the ring answers to sauron alone
it's like wait bro who even are you and
strider's elf friend legloss drops the
truth bomb his real name is aragorn and
he's the long-lost descendant of the
ancient line of kings heir to the throne
of gondor now it's like look the ring
must be destroyed so the dwarf gimli is
like what are we waiting for blam nope
it's not going to be that easy the ring
was forged in mount doom only there can
it be unmade it must be taken deep into
mordor and cast back into the fires from
once it came but that's a tall order one
does not simply walk into mordor
everyone's arguing about who should
carry it and frodo baggins realizes his
adventure is just getting started he
volunteers airbornes like you have my
sword legolas and my bow gimli and my
axe and boromir's coming too although he
also fights with the sword so he can't
really say that again and samwise
gamgee's sticking around too as well as
mary and pippin who are questionably
useful and now the fellowship of the
ring has assembled they set off for a
lot more walking but not just normal
walking super epic walking yes when the
music swells you know this shot oh so
good
gimlin is a shortcut through the dwarven
mines of moria but when they get inside
they realize this is no mine it is a
tomb because all the dwarves have been
killed pretty soon gandalf gets lost i
have no memory of this place and there
they realize someone's following them
it's gollum but more on him later then
as they're reading about what happened
here pippin knocks this thing into the
well which makes the loudest noise ever
and now the orcs know they're here so
it's time for an epic fight scene yeah
yeah and it's not just orcs they have a
cave troll pretty soon they're
surrounded but wait what's this coming
that scares all the orcs off the dwarves
dealt too greedily and too deep they
awoke a demon of the ancient world the
balrog as they flee across this
unreasonably narrow bridge gandalf stops
to 1v1 this thing you
shall not pass
and indeed boom the bridge crumbles
under the balrog and he falls down but
with his fire whip oh gets gandalf's
foot fly you fools and gandalf falls
into the abyss but the adventure goes on
next up is a woods where a bunch of
elves live led by the shiniest elf yet
lady galadriel long story short she
gives frodo a jug of shiny water then
lends the fellowship some canoes so they
get to take a break from walking for a
while and just cruise but when frodo
goes to stretch his legs he runs into
boromir and the ring's gotten to him oh
he tries to take it rudolph manages to
escape but then he runs into aragorn
it's like frodo i swore to protect you
can you protect me from yourself and so
they realize the fellowship's not gonna
work frodo has to go on his own but
meanwhile saruman's been busy building
an army worthy of border and he's not
just using normal little orcs he's
crossbred these big ass buff forks whom
do you serve sorum on they catch up with
our fellowship and it's time for another
epic orc fight mary and pippen are in
some trouble but boromir comes to the
rescue to redeem himself from betraying
frodo bosswork with the bow and arrow
hits boromir but he's such a badass he
gets up and keeps on fighting yeah after
two more arrows though he's finally done
so mary and pippen are captured and sean
bean does what sean bean does best gets
an epic death scene meanwhile frodo's
going to mordor alone but sam's not
letting that happen of course you are
and i'm coming with you these two hug it
out it's an epic bromance next up is the
two towers named for saramon's tower of
isengard and sauron's tower itself down
in mordor frodo and sam continue walking
but pretty soon they realize they don't
know where they're going luckily someone
who doesn't know the way is sneaking in
it's gollum he's fully obsessed with the
ring he calls it his precious and he's
here to get it back from the hobbits is
who stole it but the hobbits just get
the jump on him and he promises to be
nice so it's like look you're gonna lead
us to mordor but at the black gate they
realize boromir was right one does not
simply walk into mordor but gollum knows
a secret entrance now gollum wasn't
always this disgusting he used to be a
kind of normal guy named smeagle and
he's got sort of a split personality
thing going the nice smeagol and evil
gollum and for a while smeagle wins out
he's having a good time with the hobbits
learning about potatoes as for aragorn
and friends the fellowship may be broken
but they can still save mary and pippin
so they're not walking they're running
when the orcs stop for dinner they're
sad because they have no meat but they
kill one of their own looks like meat's
back on the menu boys in the cast the
hobbits try to escape but what's this
now a bunch of horsemen riding in they
are the riders of rohan and bad news
they're banished because the king is
currently possessed by sauron but good
news they killed all the orcs but more
bad news they probably killed the
hobbits too but aragorn master tracker
realizes the hobbits survived and made
their way to fangorn forest but inside
they're ambushed by the white wizard oh
no it's saruman but wait that's not
sauromon it's gandal turns out he and
the balrog had an epic fight until
finally gandalf won and smote his ruin
upon the mount inside gandalf did die
though but long story short he's not
fully human and was immediately
reincarnated not as gandalf the grey but
as gandalf the white as for marion
pippin they make friends with treebeard
the ant and they call the ant moot to
decide if the ants will join the war but
it takes them the whole movie because
ants talk really slow so our gang rides
to rohan where the super old king is
clearly possessed gandalf tries to break
the spell but it's like you have no
power here gandalf the grey but it's
like yo bro i'm gandalf the white now
and he kicked saruman out of there so
now the king is deposed he's ready to
join the fight they make for the
fortress of helm's deep but gendel
fights off on important wizard business
i'll be back on dawn on the fifth day
king theoden has a niece eowyn a shield
maiden of rohan who has a meat cute with
aragorn she tries to win his heart by
cooking him stew but she's much better
at fighting than cooking and anyway
aragorn's taken by his elf girlfriend
arwen they had a romantic moonlight
bridge scene and the whole thing is that
she's an elf so she's immortal but she's
raring to give that up to be with him i
choose a mortal life she's not really in
this story she's just chilling at
rivendell but the long distance isn't a
problem when you can meet up for sexy
elf dreams but now they're attacked by
war grinders and it's another epic
action scene but at the end airborne
gets caught and takes a tumble off the
cliff turns out he's fine though he
landed in soft water and is rescued by
his loyal horse so he makes it to helm
deep with the best sexiest door opening
ever filmed meanwhile frodo and sam are
picked up by some men and turns out this
is faramir brother of boromir he also
plans to take the ring to gondor but on
the way they're ambushed by nazgul who
have upgraded from horses into dragon
things and in the end faramir is a real
stand-up guy he's able to resist the
ring's influence and lets them go but
now saruman's been busy building an even
bigger army and so it begins the battle
of helm's deep gimli and legloss have a
fun competition to see who can kill the
most orcs but it's not even close
legolas can use his elf powers to slide
down the staircase on a shield shoenorks
as he goes he is a beast but now
sauromon has just invented gunpowder so
he sends in the torch runner and boom
blows up the wall so it's the last stand
epic charge for death and glory but wait
what time is it it's dawn of the fifth
day and gandalf's back he brought
reinforcements the writers of rohan and
so it's an epic cavalry charge and the
battle is won and as for the kill count
competition gimli claims to have
conveniently one more than legolas which
i don't buy for a second as for the ants
they decide to join the fight when they
see sauromon's been chopping down all
their trees so the ants attack eyes and
guard flood the dam and win the day so
that's one tower down but sauron himself
is an even bigger threat and now in
return of the king sauron has entered
the chat unleashes the full might of his
armies to the human capital of gondor
and the white city of minas tirith
gandolf gets another chilly reception
from denethor boromir's father and
steward of gondor remember the line of
kings died out years ago it's like yo
man you gotta fight against soron but
den thor is like ha i did my research
sauron's a hoax he's an awful father too
when vermeer comes back it's like i wish
you died instead of boromir so to make
his daddy proud fermier goes on a
suicide charge to take back the city
that's overrun with orcs so as denthor
eats lunch and pippen sings a hauntingly
beautiful song he crunches a tomato
super weird to represent he sent all
those men to their deaths so gandalf
goes behind his back has pippen like the
signal fire and it's the epic lighting
of the beacon sequence so back at rohan
aragorn gets to do what he does best and
bust into the room dramatically condor
calls for aid and rohan will answer
muster the rhohirum but they only muster
6000 spears less than half of what i
hoped for but now who's here to help
it's lord l
oh thanks man did you bring an elf army
oh no sorry but i do have a lead on
where you can find an army because in
this mountain lives a ghost army that
swore their allegiance to the king of
gondor and to help prove that you're the
true king i've brought you an epic magic
sword yes the sword that was broken that
cut off the ring it's just been sitting
in ribbondale this whole time the least
we could do was repair it for you so
airborne friends go to talk to some
ghosts it's like we do not suffer the
living to pass you will suffer me i am a
sildor's heir fight for me and i'll hold
your oath fulfilled as a prank i guess
the ghosts drop an avalanche of skulls
on them but then it's like yeah bro
we're in now back to frodo and sam who
have mostly just been doing a lot of
walking but they finally find gollum
secret stairs so now they trade out
walking for climbing now frodo is pretty
resistant to the ring but after all this
time it's starting to wear him down so
when sam's like hey man you want me to
carry it for a while frodo doesn't like
that you're trying to bore me or me bro
you gotta go home so gollum leads frodo
to the dark scary tunnel but once inside
he ditches him yeah gollum betrayed him
after all frodo remembers he's got a
bottle of shiny elf water so now he can
see what's in here and it is sheelop the
giant spider in the end she gets him
with her stinger oh things look bleak
but here to rescue him is sam who
followed him here let him go you filth
now sam is way outclassed in this fight
but he gets a lucky shot and scares
shiela but now it looks like frodo's
dead don't go where i can't follow but
turns out that poison just paralyzes him
frodo's still alive and now the full
armies of mordor have made it to minas
tierreth denethor gives an uninspiring
speech flee flee for your lives so
gandalf finally smacks this guy and
takes charge of the defenses it's
another big siege battle that lasts like
two hours eventually they bring up a
massive battering ram so cool it has its
own name grand and yeah long story short
the the city's in trouble earlier by the
way pharamir miraculously made it back
and now denethor is ready to do a double
funeral pyre even though pharamir is
actually still alive pippin's gotta jump
in there to save him and a flaming
denethor yeets himself off the balcony
so things look bleak but wait what's
this the writers of rohan have arrived
just in time again theoden king gives an
epic battle speech right now for ruin
and the world's ending and as the rohan
music swells everyone's on their feet
cheering yes so epic but sauron's got
his own surprise cavalry enforcements in
the form of holy fonts which are
basically giant elephants and to make
things worse a nazgul gets king there
and eowyn jumps in to save him and he
takes that thing's head off but this is
not just any nas ghoul it's the leader
of the nazgul the witch king fool no man
can kill me but mary the hobbit can stab
him in the ankles and ao wins like boom
i am no man oh stabbed in the face now
aragorn and friends finally arrive with
the ghost army and it's basically just
cleanup at this point legolas pulls his
best stunt yet and single-handedly takes
out this olefont slides down its trunk
that still only counts as one and this
invincible ghost army is super helpful
but their contract was just for one
battle but it's not over yet this was
but a taste of sauron's forces it all
comes down to frodo in the ring sam did
rescue frodo so the mission's still on
and now they're closer to mount doom
than ever but an army of orcs is in the
way so aragorn hatch is a crazy plan to
march on the black gate itself
draw out sauron's armies and buy clear
passage for frodo and sam aragorn gives
his own epic battle speech the day may
come when the strength of men fails but
it is not this day never thought i'd die
fighting side by side with an elf what
about side by side with a friend aye i
could do that so while everyone out
there is having an epic battle the real
fate of middle earth is in the hands of
two walking hobbits and this is their
hardest walking yet the ring gets
heavier the closer they get and finally
frodo's pooped but sam's not done yet
maybe i can't carry it for you but i can
carry you
oh samwisegamgee mvp so they finally
made it to mount doom all frodo has to
do is let go but the ring is not gonna
let that happen it finally overwhelms
frodo the ring is mine and oh frodo puts
it on but stills thinking about is
gollum and now he's ready to take back
his precious jumps on there and bites
frodo's finger off yes gollum finally
has his precious back but frodo's ready
to fight for it so these two grappling
and oh off the cliff so in the end it is
gollum who accidentally saves
middle-earth as he terminator twos down
into the lava frodo managed to hang on
and sam's right there don't you let go
and as the ring is destroyed sauron
realizes maybe he shouldn't have tied
his life force to a piece of jewelry
because his whole tower crumples and
blam sauron all the way defeated and
everything in mordor was connected to
wi-fi of the rings so it all comes
crashing down
now gandalf rides in to pick up the
hobbits with eagle uber and before you
ask no they couldn't have just flown the
ring to mordor in the first place and so
the day is saved aragorn's officially
crowned king and marries his hot elven
girlfriend he goes to see the hobbits my
friends you bow to no one and the whole
kingdom kneels to our unlikely heroes
and thus begins a half hour of fake out
endings cause it looks like it could be
this but actually we get to go home to
the shire first but we're not done yet
sam gets married and frodo writes a book
finally the last of the elves are
leaving middle-earth for their
heaven-type place across the sea and
bilbo baggins is coming with him but
wait a second frodo's going with them
too yeah he was too scarred by this
adventure he can't go back to a normal
life and so frodo baggins set sail for
america and that's where the lord of the
oh wait actually we get to see sam had
some kids first and that's where the
lord of the rings trilogy comes to an
end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]